and they're very attractive men they're
good politicians
and i think they'll be they'll be a
benefit to their nation and they'll be
of
benefit to the alliance with the united
states our guest tonight has been
nathaniel thayer director of asian
studies
at the johns hopkins university school
of advanced international studies
thank you very much for being with us
thank you we will be back in
just a couple of minutes with another
guest james galbraith who was from the
lyndon johnson school of public affairs
at the university of texas
stay with us if you were interested in
the same general subject
at the end of each week the top news
stories are reviewed by a group of
journalists and
c-span viewers tune in for a re-air of
the journalist roundtable call-in
program
saturdays at 9 00 pm eastern time 6 p.m
on the west coast during the month of
april
c-span is proud to participate in
national cable month
the cable industries focus on the
diversity of programs available to cable
subscribers
cable and broadcast television satellite
technology
radio and the printed medium all our
issues to be examined on c-span's
communications today we'll track
legislation through the house and senate
and explore the world of modern
communications through seminars
interviews and more
communications today saturdays beginning
at 11 a.m eastern
8 a.m pacific time on c-span
politicians foreign leaders today's
newsmakers
at the national press club watch them on
c-span
saturdays at 6 pm eastern time 3 pacific
c-span is the cable industry's public
affairs network
since 1979 c-span has provided
nationwide audiences
and insiders look at the democratic
process
if you have a comment about our network
please write to us
our address is c-span 444
north capitol street northwest suite
number 412
washington dc and the zip code is two
zero
zero zero one
did you know that c-span publishes a
weekly newspaper
it's called the c-span update and it's a
useful companion to your c-span viewing
in its 12 pages you'll find stories
about our public affairs programming
articles concerning the issues events
and newsmakers we cover
there's information about our network
and feedback from viewers just like you
plus a pull out section with our general
schedule including air times for special
programs we know about in advance
four dollars a year brings you 50 issues
of the c-span update
to place your order now call
1-800-346-8800
use your credit card or we'll be glad to
bill you
this week's update announces an
improvement in pre-recorded scheduled
information
now available by phone and we spotlight
democracy in the philippines and ethnic
tensions in the soviet union
if you order the c-span update now
you'll receive a free gift
c-span's elegant 10th anniversary poster
24 by 36 inches
and suitable for framing call
1-800-346-88
and we'll send you our anniversary
poster and 50 issues of the c-span
update both for just 24. call now
[Music]
james galbraith associate professor at
the lyndon johnson school of public
affairs at the university of texas
and author of the new book balancing
acts technology finance and the american
future
will you begin by telling us a little
about that book what its major theme is
the big theme of balancing acts
is that the american economy
can resume its role as
the leading economy in the world as the
instrument
of uh industrial transformation in the
world
what's required for that to happen are
some changes
in the way we conduct macroeconomic
policy in this country
and the book describes what some of
those changes ought to be we're going to
ask you at this point to define
macroeconomic policy
taxing spending and the
policies that the federal reserve
employs to affect
interest rates and money because the
program we just completed
uh dealt entirely with japan can you
talk a little
i know your book directs its uh self to
some of the problems we face with the
japanese can you direct
yourself to that point at the moment i
argue that the united states
competes in world markets with japan
with germany primarily also with other
uh smaller advanced economies
in the world markets for advanced
technology
goods for capital goods for goods that
are produced
with science with technology
with highly skilled workers those are
the markets
we ought to be concerned with uh it's
the
size and success of those industries
that policy ought to be
trying to foster and can you compare
the highly skilled worker in japan to
the highly skilled worker in the united
states
on average i think the american worker
is more highly skilled
and what does that mean in terms of our
global competition with the japanese
it means that the industries where we
have our strongest advantage
are such industries as aerospace
computers machinery of all kinds
scientific instruments energy equipment
medical equipment
farm equipment and where the japan the
japanese have been moving into some of
those areas
but if you look at the present structure
of japanese industry
the thing that they sell to us an
overwhelming number is automobiles
which is a different a different order
of uh
technological sophistication
we were talking about the aerospace with
our previous guests in discussing the
fsx controversy the controversy over to
what degree the united states should
make technology available to japan as it
develops the fsx jet
fighter can you sort of pick up on that
and give us your feelings
i can't comment specifically on the fsx
deal
i would expect uh that both countries uh
would would benefit from it i don't see
any particular problem we don't have a
we're not in a security race with the
japanese and i don't see why we can't
cooperate on
certain specific projects you say in the
opening chapter of your book that the
united states
faces a choice between alternative
programs
of industrial development uh explain
that
well i think uh there are uh two broadly
speaking two kinds of uh policies one
can pursue
one can try to restore the industrial
structure of the united states as it was
say in the 1950s with a
primary emphasis on consumers goods and
and goods that are sold
in the american market or one can foster
the growth of those industries
that do best by exporting and that sell
into world markets
now i've already mentioned what those
what those are fundamentally
uh and i think we should do the latter
because i think those industries
are the ones that will yield the highest
living standards the highest
wage levels for american workers our
guest tonight is james galbraith
associate professor at the lyndon
johnson school of public affairs
at the university of texas and the
author of the book we've
been discussing balancing acts uh you
also co-authored with uh robert
heilbrunner
the 1987 book the economic problem
you were also we must note the son of
john kenneth
galbeth a very famous american and the
author of
must be a scorer or more books oh more
than a score yes
tell us a little about your
relationships with your father you seem
to be following
in his very distinguished footsteps uh
uh becoming an author yourself can you
tell us
and you know of course he was was and is
a distinguished distinguished
economist uh did you was there an early
age where you decided
it's been a good life for my father and
i'm going to give the gift
a go myself i don't think so i think i
decided i would become an economist
late in my college career and i don't
think there was ever any
implicit understanding in our family
that i would become one
uh i since making that decision i've had
a
close professional relationship with my
father which continues
when you write a book do you first
discuss it with your father does he is
he a
proofreader of sorts for you or an
editor i
we didn't talk very much about the
argument in this book but he did read it
uh and he provided a lot of editing help
his writing is substantially more
practice than mine
do you find yourself generally in
agreement on economic issues
i would say there is a broad
philosophical agreement and a number of
areas of differences within that
you uh say again in the opening chapters
of your book that it is a brief for the
outward
looking program would you go into that
in a little greater detail
well uh i argue
that if american industry has
the right prices and strong demand in
global markets it will compete
successfully
against the japanese against the germans
against any comers
because we fundamentally have a lot of
flexibility
and a lot of talent in the us economy
the problem has been since 1982
uh for a long period the dollar was much
too high
and we have had a worldwide
recession and a continuing depression in
the developing world
and i would like to see us help the
developing countries particularly
snap out of that depression and again
become growing markets
for the kinds of goods that we export i
think if that happens
those industries in the united states
will prosper and over the long run
not only americans but people all over
the world
will have much higher living standards
than might otherwise be the case
if my memory surged we had a balance of
trade
deficit of about 55 billion dollars last
year with the japanese
if we can compete successfully with them
why aren't we
well i don't think we will ever have a
balance of trade
in balance or in surplus with the
japanese they sell consumer goods to us
they buy their imports the raw materials
from the middle east
from australia and elsewhere and they're
not going to turn around and buy oil
from us
rather than from saudi arabia after all
the saudis who have it uh
that's not the important thing from the
u.s the important thing is
is to return our overall balance of
trade
to approximate balance uh to end this
debilitating series of deficits this
accumulation
of external debt i think we can do that
uh
in by selling into other parts of the
world economy to europe
to latin america to the east
and we ought to work on on that kind of
of a global strategy
is it possible to bring our trade
into balance in the united states
without reducing
living standards for the american worker
i think so yes what are the problems in
that area
well the fundamental obstacle
is slow growth and uh in the world
economy
and uh too high value of the dollar so
that our exporters
who've had a couple of very good years
since we depreciated the dollar in 1985
86 are now once again running into
the price barrier uh in their
international sales
and we need further steps now to assure
that the growth that they've enjoyed
in their sales since since 1985
continues
we'll be going to the telephones in just
a few minutes please call us if you have
a question or a comment again our guest
is
james galbraith associate professor of
the lyndon johnson school of public
affairs at the university of texas
and the son of john kenneth galbraith
you say in your book that in order to
get our economy back into balance and
moving forward again
there has to be a decline in interest
rates how would you bring that about
i would uh put together a package of
measures very simple package
the first one would raise taxes it would
raise
tax rates effective not immediately
but a year or so from now and not by
enough to close the budget deficit to
reduce it to zero
but just by enough to reduce it to say
100 billion dollars
that would be a very clear a very
decisive step
it would tell the world and it would
tell the financial markets
and it would tell the federal reserve
that we have acted
to correct the deficit the budget
deficit
problem i would then ask the federal
reserve as part of the same
package of policies to ease monetary
policy
lower interest rates i think that shift
would work
it would not produce a recession and it
would provide
uh the kind of uh impetus to
investment uh and
also to to to trade to exports that
would keep the economy growing
uh for the next two or three years
i think we need to quote president bush
at this point uh
read my lips no new taxes what do you do
about that
well i think president bush left himself
quite a number of uh
of outs uh no new taxes for example uh
he's also been been heard to
allow aides to hint that taxes next year
might be all right it was just a pledge
that applied to 1989
but fundamentally uh i would remind
the administration that uh
john maynard keynes the british
economist was once
a criticized for changing his mind about
something and
he confronted his critic and said
when circumstances change i change my
views what what do you do
sir pittsburgh pennsylvania go ahead
please
hi pittsburgh hello
pittsburgh pennsylvania go ahead please
am i through i think i want to say that
a gentleman first of all thanking him
for
writing this book and you know
distinguished father
is our biggest problem in foreign aid uh
the amounts of vast amounts of money we
literally give away versus trading away
for products
and things of that nature you'd feel
that a country that wanted to maintain
itself worldwide would not just give out
money as i understand it in bushel
basket with nothing in return
helping some countries even to develop
their own planes and weaponry and what
have you
versus binding out of you know our own
country and
the second thing i would like to suggest
to the gentleman that he
donate a book to the congress and center
and the senate
thank you for the second suggestion i
have sent the book to a few
of my former employers in in the
congress
um i think
that we do need to restore our trade
position
and that is a very important uh
observation
uh we can only do that though because if
we help set the conditions
under which other countries can grow
because we have an enormous power of
influence
over the world economy and we're not
using it
properly now right now we're letting for
example the latin american debt crisis
affecting brazil and mexico which have
had a decline in their import levels of
40 percent
phenomenal fall in their in their wage
levels
uh since 1982 we're dragging that out
to no good purpose and the industries
that are suffering
are our own export industries which are
losing sales that they could otherwise
have had
you discussed the problem of inflation
at the considerable length
in your book and as i read it you would
give the president more power to control
inflation how would you do that well i
think that the system we have now
in which nobody wants to talk about
inflation
while it's accelerating you can't find
inflation on the front pages of the
papers but you can find it on the
financial pages already
every day nobody wants to talk about it
as a political matter
until it is out of control until it is
becomes a political crisis
at which point the problem gets turned
over to the federal reserve
uh to mr greenspan who can only deal
with it
by raising interest rates and throwing
people out of work
that's a very bad system that imposes
enormous costs on people and it also
i argue in the book has a permanent
effect
on our industrial structure when we
throw the economy deliberately into a
recession
we lose industries that we could save
and that won't come back
because in the next expansion those
industries aren't going to be
in youngstown ohio or in milwaukee
wisconsin
they're going to be in south korea or in
singapore and that is something people
need to be aware
uh that we are on that track now toward
accelerating inflation
followed by another uh exasperated
throwing in of the towel by the
administration turning the problem over
to the federal reserve
inflation in this country is currently
running i believe at about five percent
just up a point there or so
from last year in china where students
are demonstrating by the hundreds of
thousands so inflation is thirty percent
uh is five percent really a figure to be
concerned about
i think it's a matter of the tolerance
of any individual country
uh in india uh zero percent inflation is
what's required
in brazil they're happy if they get by
with a hundred percent inflation
in this country uh i think we start
worrying if it goes above six or seven
percent
and we're moving in that direction
louisville kentucky please join us
yes sir i'm not economist but i guess i
have an idea
uh i believe that
uh deficit will be declined in
america i'm american citizen i speak
with accent no problem i
hope is
no way first of all is to improve
the export as long as the foreign policy
is not good enough because a lot of
world markets has
closed in the face of american goods
before because of the bad foreign policy
let me give you an example
in the middle east for instance america
is putting the old eggs
in the basket of israel and
they export nothing to israel and they
export something but they don't cash
money
all the things they export are free
almost
but they are losing about 23 25
different
countries and as a result maybe 20
billion dollars lost
why such why such foreign policy why why
such they harm their economy
america economy let's get an answer at
this point
i think that the u.s ought to sell
freely uh into
all markets where our security is not
involved
i'm an economist and i'm not going to
get into question specific questions of
where uh
limits on on on technology might might
be appropriate
there are some obviously in the nuclear
area for example
we have those how about the problem of
opening up the japanese market where
american businessmen often complain
they're just not permitted to sell their
good
i think that's that's a real issue and i
think that's an appropriate question for
for hard-nosed diplomacy and i support
that but fundamentally that is not going
to solve the trade deficit
what's will solve the trade deficit is a
change in the
world pattern of growth and in our
exchange rate policy
carlsbad california go ahead please
good day hi i just wanted to say i
uh i see a displeasing consistency
of mr galbraith's views with those of
his father
both of them have the goal
of printing paper money
and raising taxes as a means of
centralizing wealth and power
in the central government and we got
ourselves into this trouble
of a savings and loan crisis and massive
third world debt
by that policy with his father advising
kennedy
johnson and carter right on up into the
point where we got a flight from the
dollar in 79. so i'd like to have mr
galway comment on that
okay thanks for your comment well you uh
attribute a
a lot of power to my father and of
course it's all true
the your point
uh about for example the savings alone
uh starts that process much too early
we got into the savings and loan crisis
to take your specific point
because we threw away the legitimate and
necessary
responsibilities of government the
regulatory responsibilities for
government
over runaway financial institutions and
we did that
in 1981 in 1982
and subsequently that's when the savings
and loan crisis
uh ballooned to its present dimensions
and right now under republican
administration
there's an acknowledgment of that and of
the need to
have a legitimate role for
a financial regulation and there are
other areas where that's true
but fundamentally that's not what my
book advocates my book
makes the case that the private sector
in the american economy
is a strong and vibrant and resilient
and flexible private sector
it's an endorsement of the
entrepreneurial
and industrial ability of american
business i'm not part of the group that
argues that we're in
a period of stagnation because of
corporate
incapacity my my argument is with
policy with government policy i think
that is the problem
uh to that extent uh you've uh
my my views may not be so very far from
the ones you've just expressed
that may read you if i may at this point
a quotation from your book
quote we cannot maintain a comparative
advantage in our
older consumer-oriented manufacturing
industries
at the present national living standards
that's right if we take
the view that what we need to
do to compete is somehow to
compete in automobiles and
other basic consumer goods industries
where our where we were
industrial industrially preeminent 30
years ago
we will find that the only way to do
that is to reduce our wages
to the levels of the koreas and the
spains
where those sectors are emerging uh and
so i argue that you what you need
is industrial transformation uh you need
to be in the advanced technology sectors
where we can uh do what we're best at
and get well paid for it
not that we won't continue to have an
automobile industry but
it should not be the thing which is
growing most rapidly in our economy
minneapolis minnesota go ahead please
yes um i realize it's not
excuse me around this machine
i realize it's not sophisticated to
promote a buy america
presumably the american will necessarily
buy the best product
but if we are to estimate the
loss to the american family of you might
say
five acres of american farmland for
every car that gets bought
and if the american buyer would estimate
this
as he goes to buy his car wouldn't he be
more inclined to buy the american
product
it's poor quality and outstanding and
isn't this something that we could
promote
and you know from the highest level
government
and caller without any shame but i ask
you at this point to explain that
analogy
the loss of five acres of farmland for
every uh
foreign car that is bought well sir
the car of course depreciates after ten
years to zero
and fifteen thousand dollars
that we paid a japanese car seller
appreciates to maybe thirty thousand and
say we're looking at
uh three thousand dollars per acre of
marginal farmland and uh
this falls into their hands with every
car that we buy
okay thank you for your comment we'll
get an answer at this point
well the analogy is apt but there are
many products
uh in which american industries are
world leaders
where they can sell what they produce
computers for example aerospace i've
gone through the list of
types of machinery and equipment they're
not the sort of thing you have in your
house
but they are the sort of thing that
power uh your factories and uh
and produce the products that you have
in your house uh
so my argument is that the world
should buy american and i i believe the
world will
if we don't obstruct it from doing so by
keeping our prices too high
and keeping uh and
not moving to uh generate the kind of
growth in their
purchasing power that will enable them
to come into the market for our goods
there is already concern being expressed
in this country that the japanese are
moving so rapidly in computers
that they may one day dominate the world
computer market today
the way they are dominating auto sales
today
well this is the kind of thing that
motivated me to write the book
i think we were in a very strong
position until 1981
82 but with the tremendous
appreciation of the dollar we lost
a lot of market share in advanced
technology industries i think we have
the capacity to regain a lot of that
or with changes in policy but if if
if we don't do something reasonably soon
we may run out of time and we may find
that the japanese are indeed
acquiring unassailable position in many
of those advanced industries
that would be a tragedy well you seem to
have a call from kuwait and i
hope that means the country of kuwait go
ahead please
hello you're absolutely right this is
the country of kuwait good evening
gentlemen
hi uh if i may ask mr galbraith uh two
questions if you don't mind
uh the first question is as we are all
aware japan is the wealthiest
country in the world today and the
biggest lender
while the us has the largest trade
deficit
as well as the biggest borrower today so
could mr galbraith explain how can the
u.s
change its position reduce its deficit
and take its previous standing
economically
and the second question if i may is that
is it true that u.s capital owns
a substantial share of the japanese
multinationals
thank you uh the book is about
the the first part of your first
question
how the u.s can indeed eliminate
its deficit position in world markets
and move
away from this drift to being the
world's
largest uh debtor nation uh
the policies start with the basic uh
changes that i mentioned earlier we need
to reduce our budget deficits i advocate
a a rise in tax rates to achieve that
because it's the simplest and most
effective thing
we need to reduce our interest rates we
need to bring
the dollar to a competitive level and we
need
to resolve the debt crisis of the
developing countries
so that they can come back into the
market for our export goods
that's the package that seems to me is
necessary to achieve
a correction of our
trade accounts and the second question
as i understood it is it true
that the united states companies own the
biggest share of japanese multinationals
i have no specific information on the
ownership of japanese corporations okay
sorry about the second question but
thank you for the call from kuwait
the second is a little closer to home
state college pennsylvania go ahead
please
yes professor galbraith seemed to
indicate that
he felt president bush should change his
mind and accept the tax increase
a two-part question would the tax
increase not make it easier
for our democratic congress to increase
the level of government spending
and the second part don't most rigorous
economists believe that for a fixed
level of government
spending the financing of that spending
is irrelevant
okay um i think that the president
maintains
very substantial leverage over spending
it would not be possible for the
democratic congress to add
new programs without the president's
consent
now i think that some reallocation of
expenditure
toward public capital formation
uh is is a good idea but most of that
can be financed
uh out of uh the diminishing share of
the budget that it will be going to the
military in
any event and out of
declining interest payments if the
policy package i advocate goes into
effect
and out of economic growth so there's no
real need
to raise the rate at which uh total
expenditures are rising
now as far as the second part of your uh
question is concerned uh you raise a
matter which is a
matter of considerable high brow dispute
and i would not say
that most rigorous economists are on one
side of that argument
or another you've got plenty of rigorous
economists on both sides
colorado springs colorado go ahead
please how you doing
i don't know if you know the answer is
this tv flag
what's that is it tv too loud uh i think
it's all right uh why don't you try it
and we'll see
uh i don't know if you know the answer
is not i got a couple questions first
uh you know the miles per gallon that
the government
forces on the detroit uh
mileage is it does that apply to the
foreigners too yes or no
i believe it does i would assume it does
it does okay i didn't know that
now you talk about exports and all that
how come you know we've got these troops
all over the world
you know their paycheck goes into the
foreigners economy we pay
rent is that
included in our exports yes or no if not
why
and i got one more thing about japan
um okay go ahead
now everybody keeps comparing the
japanese they're so great that they're
so great at that
as far as i'm concerned they're
copycatters everything they got they got
from us they got the vcr and everything
else
they just undercut our market got
subsidized by the government
their government until they drove our
businesses out now
they want the ssx if they're so high
tech you know everything and got
everything why can't they make their own
planes
no they want to have our technology to
get into their aircraft industry and
military aircraft so they can undercut
us again
okay let's stop you there and see if we
can get some answers
okay um on the question of
technology sharing uh and and
security commitments of course we have
those security commitments
uh as a result of a political uh
agreements that we've undertaken to
defend korea for example
to defend europe uh and i'm not
proposing
to change those without uh a general
relaxation of tensions
what i would suggest though is that the
the size of these commitments
while it's not insubstantial this is not
what's causing our problem
uh in international trade we've had
those commitments
for uh 30 and 40 years
we've only had our trade since 1983 in
1984
so if you're looking for the cause look
at the changes in policy
that we instituted uh under president
reagan
that's where the the difficulties that
we currently face and that we need to
deal with
now began to arise okay one other
question i believe was
uh are is the cost of maintaining
american troops overseas in places like
korea i suppose
uh included as an export so it would add
to our
negative balance of trade no it's not an
export powers uh
the i was trying to to think whether
this
the services uh that they provide to our
gi's is are are an export of theirs
i haven't got an immediate answer to
that question accounting third question
he
seemed to proceed from the presumption
that the japanese are guilty of
unfair trade practices that that is an
issue that is under investigation
by a commission here in washington i
believe is it not that
well we have uh innumerable
investigations of
unfair trade practices uh and i'm not
uh opposed to uh working to
a toward a level playing field in world
trade but once again
this is not the reason why we have a
trade deficit we've had
these disputes with the japanese and
others for decades
but once again the trade deficit has
only been with us for five or six years
and the next caller may have to help me
with the pronunciation is it uh
whopping jews falls new york okay
okay i got a question here that sounds
like in order to balance
our trade uh deficit we're gonna have to
exploit the third world
to have them become our customers but my
basic question is
that one of jamie's proposals is to
control the federal reserve
we never hear anything about any
suggestion to change the japanese
banking system
why what is the difference how does the
japanese banking system work
treatise could be written on that
subject
many have
the uh uh
on the on your point about the third
world i i would not call it exploitation
uh i think we need to be at the
forefront
of fostering development and growth in
the third world
that will make those countries markets
for our investment goods
as we become an increasing market for
their consumer goods i think that's
entirely natural
and it's a process which enriches both
sides
i think that's what the japanese have
been doing in their relationship
with other with the developing countries
of east asia and it's one of the reasons
why they
their their trading patterns have been
so much more successful
in this decade than ours have been uh
now as far as the
the federal reserve as against the
japanese
central bank uh the bank of japan i
would
uh there is certainly a large difference
and the big difference
is that our federal reserve uh stands
apart
from the executive branch uh the
central bank of japan is a part of their
ministry of finance of their treasury
department
and that's an arrangement which enables
them to coordinate their policy
in a way which we have a lot of
difficulty doing and i do think it would
be a good idea
if our policy central bank policies
and tax and spending policies were much
more closely coordinated than they are
now
let me try you quickly on another
quotation before we take a final
phone call too quote it is a common
place of modern technology
that there is a high measure of
certainty that problems have solutions
before there is knowledge of how they
are to be solved
what's your reaction to that sounds
familiar but i can't quite play it
that's from uh your one of your father's
books we're playing a little trick on
you here
uh that's the galbraith uh reader but uh
it includes some passages from the
industrial state is that a new
industrial state which is one of your
father's better known books
reminding you again that our guest is
the son of john kenneth
galbraith we have about three minutes
left and we'll take a call from
lafayette indiana go ahead please uh
yes i'm going to make two or three
uh make it a couple of you will since we
have three minutes left
okay yes
uh can you hear me we hear you very well
if you'll go ahead
uh i'm going to make two or three
comments and then i would like to your
mr galbraith to give us an analysis on
what he sees in regards to export
one state government in the united
states
is sponsoring funding or providing
manufacturing locations for the japanese
people yeah we're going to stop you
there and get the
an answer to that because we have only a
couple minutes left that is quite true
that is happening particularly in your
part of the country
uh it's an again a consequence
of uh having a uh uh the
the larger policies which i've been
discussing
uh i don't think it's a particularly
healthy thing to have to import our
capital equipment in order to provide
adequate jobs
for american workers those industries
ought to be the ones
that we should be uh fostering uh in uh
in the united states in industries like
uh
cummins engine for example in your part
of the world we have about 90 seconds
left
you call in your book for reductions in
military spending
how big a reduction are you talking
about well
uh i use the
base of a of an eight percent reduction
which is not very large
how you how you measure that depends
upon
what your starting point is we are
already reducing military expenditure
substantially below the track that the
administration wanted
that's essentially the baseline i'm
using so i'm not calling for in any
sense a radical
reduction in our military commitments my
argument is the military
ought to be funded at the level which is
determined by national defense
not by economics but i think we can live
within that requirement
our guest tonight has been james
galbraith associate professor at the
lyndon b johnson school of public
affairs
at the university of texas and author of
the book balancing acts
thank you very much for being with us
tonight and thanks to our c-span viewers
for your questions and comments
have a pleasant evening
[Music]
join c-span sunday at about 505 pm
eastern
time for a meeting held this week by the
house budget committee
as it marks up the fiscal year 1990
federal budget
members make line by line evaluations of
the package
and make final decisions on the tax and
spending provisions
congressman leon panetta democrat from
california chairs those proceedings
that's the house budget committee markup
of the 1990 federal budget
sunday at 505 pm eastern time which is
just past
two in the west coming up next a
briefing held today by the office of the
u.s trade representative
[Music]
good evening from the nation's capital
join us monday morning at 8 45 a.m
eastern time for a live you were calling
among our guests at this round table
looking at the first 100 days of the
bush presidency
will be paul weirich the president of
the free congress foundation
and stephen hess a senior fellow at the
brookings institution
our overnight schedule begins in a few
moments with today's news conference
held by the office of the u.s trade
representative
the general counsel releases the
national trade estimate figures
after that the vice president of the
european community sir leon britain
speaks on europe 1992
that's at a luncheon held today by the
british american business association
this evening at 9 05 pm eastern time dr
frank young the commissioner of the food
and drug administration
addresses a meeting of the american
legislative exchange council
after that we hear highlights of today's
session in the canadian house of commons
you'll see prime minister's question
time and the legislative session
as members continued debate on the
federal budget that was leaked to the
press prior to its consideration
in the commons just past 1 am eastern
time 1005 pacific
we re-hear today's news conference held
by the general counsel to the u.s trade
representative
also today in washington panama's
minister of foreign affairs held a
briefing on the political situation in
this country
he met first with the general secretary
of the organization of american states
then had remarks afterward today on
c-span we brought you live coverage of a
symposium on campaign reform
sponsored by the project for
comprehensive campaign reform
and the league of women voters a number
of scholars and political consultants
were at that meeting
and that's on our schedule for 2 10 a.m
eastern time
following that we rear the news
conference held by the panamanian
foreign minister jorge eduardo ritter
saturday morning at 6 20 a.m eastern
time jack kemp
the secretary of housing and urban
development is the guest at the american
legislative exchange council
that's followed at 7 10 a.m eastern time
with the remarks of president george
bush before that same group
after that we rear the news conference
today by the general counsel of the u.s
trade representative
and at 8 a.m eastern time 5 pacific
saturday morning
we re-air a call-in program from earlier
in the week on the bipartisan budget
plan for fiscal year 1990 that was
marked up on the house this week
viewers questioned the ranking
republican member on the house budget
committee minnesota congressman bill
frenzel
that's a brief look at our schedule our
next update will be at about 10 pm
eastern time this evening
thanks for joining us
[Music]
as part of our 10th anniversary c-span
acknowledges our viewers from across the
country
this week c-span recognizes a special
viewer from cherry hill new jersey
bud harris the founder of friends of
c-span
he's a retired insurance executive with
an interest in reading music
and politics bud watches c-span on new
york times cable company and on his own
satellite dish
my taste in television is
towards talk
as opposed to entertainment
entertainment shows like sitcoms which i
just don't care for
and the anthologies which i
don't care for either
so that is my taste in television so
when i discovered
a c-span
i don't remember what was on when i
first discovered it
whether it was the house or
one of your call-in shows i just don't
remember it goes back
so so far all i know is that i
was hooked c-span's look at american
democracy
is available to more than 43 million
cable television households around the
nation
did you know that c-span publishes a
weekly newspaper
it's called the c-span update and it's a
useful companion to your c-span viewing
in its 12 pages you'll find stories
about our public affairs programming
articles concerning the issues events
and newsmakers we cover
there's information about our network
and feedback from viewers just like you
plus a pull out section with our general
schedule
including air times for special programs
we know about in advance
just twenty 24 a year brings you 50
issues of the c-span update
to place your order now call
1-800-346-8800
use your credit card or we'll be glad to
bill you
this week